apparemment c'est un camping en fait ces
tentes et ces caravanes sont implanté
sur des propriétés privées et sur l'Î de
c'est totalement interdit puisque depuis
1979 l'Î est un site placé 2000 campeurs
qui possèd le terrain depuis parfois
plus de 30 ans ont peur de perdre leur
coin de paradis on habite appartement à
côté de
l a pas mal de monde alors
V vill de il a décidé avec les autres
élus de Lille de faire appliquer la loi
nous appliquons la loi nous dressons
procèsverbal ça ira chez le procureur et
puis le tribunal jugera et puis il y
aura une une astreinte financière qui là
sera lourde donc les gens seront bien
obligés d'évacuer sinon ils seront
obligés de payer et c'est comme ça qu'on
les tiendra il y a pas de il y a pas de
police il y a rien du tout c'est pas
c'est pas là le
problème régulièrement les campeurs sur
propriété privées manifestent c'est
clair ils ne veulent pas quitter un
terrain ou souvent ils ont procédé à de
nombreux aménagements envoyez-moi le CRS
envoyez-moi les gardes mobiles je sais
pas qui mettez-moi une bombe mais pour
l'instant je suis là j'en bougerai pas
selon la loi seul le ministre de
l'Environnement Dominique voineet peut
accorder des dérogations on voudrait
dire à Mame voineet que en fait la
protection du site de l'île- de Ray ne
passe pas systématiquement par
l'élimination des campeurs caravaniers
sur parcelle privée que même avec des
campeurs caravaniers sur parcelle privée
dans l'île- de Ray le site peut être
protégé et l'environnement aussi
l'association de défense des campeurs
privés demande des regroupements de
terrain comme ici impossible répondent
les élus c'est désormais illégal affaire
compliqué le vent n'a pas fini de
souffler sur l'île de
Ray